هي صاحبة شخصية قوية
، مدافعة دائما عن القضايا العربية
أوكل لها والدها مهمة الدفاع عن صدامحسين
وورثت عن والدها العقيد العزة والشموخ والقومية العربية
جمعت بين الحداثة والتقدم
وبين التمسك بالقيم والمحافظة والوقار الاجتماعي
وضعت في القائمة السوداء للاتحاد الأوروبي
لكن تم إزالة اسمها بعد سنوات قليلة
كان والدها يجهزها لتصبح أول رئيسة لليبيا من النساء
، لذكائها ورجاحة عقلها
(عائشة القذافي،،للقصة بقية)
ولدت عام ١٩٧٦
واختار لها العقيد اسم عائشة وهو ذات اسم أمه عائشة بن نيران
درست الحقوق في الجامعة ثم أكملت الماجستير
وأرادت إكمال شهادة الدكتوراة في جامعة السوربون في فرنسا
لكنها قررت فجأة قطع دراستها
ورأت أنه من العبث دراسة شيء لا وجود له
ثم حصلت على شهادة الدكتوراة في القانون الدولي بعد ذلك
وفي عام ٢٠٠٩ صدر كتاب عنها في سوسيرا بعنوان
، عائشة القذافي، أميرة السلام
تزوجت عائشة بأحد ضباط الجيش الذي ينتمي لقبيلتها وهو أحمد القذافي
وأثناء محاكمة الرئيس العراقي صدام حسين في عام ٢٠٠٤
شكلت عائشة فريق محاماه بتمويلها الخاص
ومنضمة في الوقت ذاته لفريق المحماه للدفاع عن صدام حسين
الدكتورة عائشة القذافي أن وجودها في هيئة الدفاع عن صدام حسين
يأتي بحكم اختصاصها المهني كمحامية
وضمن المهام الخيرية الإنسانية التي تقوم بها الجمعية
لتقديم المساعدة الى كل من يحتاج اليها
وتأمينا لحقوق الانسان محليا ودوليا
وفي العام ٢٠١١
وضع الإتحاد الأوروبي اسم عائشة القذافي
ضمن القائمة السوداء للاتحاد
، لكن هذا القرار تمت إزالته مؤخرا
بحجة أن عائشة لم تعد ثمثل تهديدا للسلم والأمن الدوليين
لكن قبل ذلك كانت منظمة الأمم المتحدة قد أعلنت عائشة القذافي
سفيرة للسلام في العام ٢٠٠٩،
تكريما لجهودها في قضايا الطفل والمرأة
كل ذلك لم يمنع عائشة أن تكون عنونا للصمود
في وجه حلف الناتو أثناء العدوان على ليبيا
خلال حياته اعتمد العقيد القذافي على عائشة كثيرا
ليس حبا فيها فقط
فهي وحيدة إلى جانب الأبناء الذكور
بل لأنها اتسمت بشخصية قيادية حازمة
وبدأت بكونها شخصية جاذبة للاستثمار لوطنها
، وعملت عائشة في مجال تطوير الاقتصاد الوطني والاستثمار
وهي لاتزال في ال٢٢
من عمرها، لكنها سرعان ما اكتسبت الخبرة في هذا المجال،
وبجمالها وأناقتها العصرية
ومحافظتها وتمسكها بالقيم والمبادئ
أقنعت المستثمرين أن هذا البلد يتجه،
نحو مستقبل أكثر تطورا وانفتاحا على العالم،
،،، أما في الفترة الأخيرة من حكم القذافي
فقد ازداد اللغط حول وريثه
وبينما كان أولاد القذافي بين التهور وقلة الخبرة
فقد برز اسم عائشة كخليفة لوالدها في الحكم
ويقول المراقبون أن القذافي كان يجهزها لخلافته
بإعطائها أدوارا سياسية كبيرة،
وهو ما استغلته عائشة الاستغلال الأمثل وكانت مؤهلة
لتصبح الرئيسة الأولى لليبيا من النساء
بعد الاستقلال خلافا للعادات الليبية
فيما لازالت الحكومة الليبية ودول حلف الناتو
يعيشون حالة من الخوف، من عودتها للواجهة
متسلقة بسلم شعبية والدها
بأدوارها المختلفة اقتصاديا وسياسيا
صارت عائشة القذافي في فترة من الفترات
هي المرشحة الوحيدة للرئاسة في ليبيا
فهل تعود قريبا
لتعيد مجد والدها العقيد؟...